[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia co el 19 a continuación algunos
de los temas que vamos a tener en el
programa de hoy la organización mundial
de la salud ha declarado como variante
de interés la variante move o también
variante de 1621 la misma ya se
presencia en colombia desde el pasado
mes de enero y si bien no es tan
extendida como la variante delta cuatro
de cada diez casos registrados en este
país suramericano son relacionados con
esta variante también tiene presencia en
otros países de la región como ecuador
como en perú también en eeuu incluso en
el reino unido- debemos preocuparnos por
ella qué características tiene esta
nueva variante lo vamos a conversar con
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez quien es
el asesor científico de france 24
hablaremos también de la situación en
costa rica y en nicaragua ambos países
centroamericanos están experimentando un
pico de contagio y altas
hospitalizaciones ambos países han roto
sus propios récords en las cifras que
han registrado a lo largo de toda esta
pandemia con costa rica diferencia de
nicaragua está muy avanzada en la
vacunación eso le ayuda y le beneficia
en algunos aspectos es por esto que los
nicaragüenses también han llamado a un
confinamiento voluntario a sus
ciudadanos con nuestra corresponsal
permanente en la ciudad de san jose
cindy regidor vamos a ver cómo está la
situación en estos dos países y después
de varios meses de cierre uruguay
decidió abrir las fronteras del país
para los extranjeros que tienen
propiedades en ese país suramericano
esto beneficia principalmente a cerca de
90.000 argentinos que tienen inmuebles
en la república oriental qué condiciones
tiene esta medida es la antesala para la
apertura de este país plenamente al
turismo que es un pilar fundamental de
la economía uruguaya esto está pasando
también de cara o tal vez pensándolo
como una antesala para el verano austral
que es de diciembre hasta marzo lo vamos
a ver en el reporte que tiene nuestra
compañera card y nada más la
corresponsal de france 24 desde la
ciudad de punta del este pues comenzamos
y lo hacemos con cifras hablamos del
avance de la pandemia para esta semana
de américa del sur comienzo por darles
datos de brasil este país sierra esta
semana con más de 20 millones 800 mil
casos de kobe 19 más de 500.000 personas
ya han perdido la vida en ese país en
bolivia allí reportan a más de 490 mil
casos más de 18.000 personas han
fallecido en bolivia vamos ahora hasta
paraguay allí contabilizan más de 458
mil casos y 15.000 personas han
fallecido y vamos al noreste de
suramérica surinam reporta más de 29 mil
900 casos ya se aproximan los 30.000 y
allí solamente 700 personas han
fallecido y vamos a finalizar este
recorrido en guyana allí las autoridades
contabilizan más de 25 mil casos y unas
600 personas han perdido la vida
bueno y damos inicio entonces a la
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez infectólogo y asesor científico de
france24 doctor pérez es bienvenido
gracias por estar con nosotros y abrimos
esta extensa agenda de consulta que
tenemos con usted vamos a hablar de la
variante muchas características tiene
esta variante y que ya tiene amplia
presencia en el país donde nos
encontramos en colombia
si hay que recordar santiago que las
variantes tienen unas características
algunas son de preocupación y otras son
de interés cuál es la diferencia en la
esta variante que fue declarar intereses
porque puede explicar la expansión de un
pico y cuando son de preocupación es
porque se puede producir por ejemplo
falta de reactividad las vacunas o
escape existen inmunológico o se puede
volver de gran preocupación cuando
digamos se encuentra con algunas
características que la hace que no se
pueda controlar hasta ahora lo que
sabemos es que es una hora del interés
significa que las mutaciones que tienen
pueden aumentar la transmisibilidad no
está claro si afecta la letalidad es
decir la capacidad de enfermar y que
está circulando desde principios del año
en el país es doctor pérez quiero
profundizar en este tema y la y la gran
preocupación que hay entre los
ciudadanos es si estamos ante una
amenaza igual o peor que la amenaza que
ya representa la variante delta que se
sabe entonces de la variante mu es mucho
más agresiva no es tan agresiva o no tan
contagiosa que es el principal factor
que caracteriza a delta
digamos que no está establecido al
parecer si tiene aumento en la
transmisibilidad pero no es comparable
con lo que sucede con la variante delta
donde ya hay una tipificación de su alta
transmisibilidad y es su capacidad de
infectar a personas que ya están
vacunadas esto no está demostrado con
esta variante y por eso se llama interés
porque se generan los estudios cómo van
a ser las características y tal vez en
un par de semanas vamos a ver más
información pero no es similar a la
variante alta y ahora no se ha
establecido que tenga mayor gravedad que
estas otras variantes que hay entonces
de acuerdo a lo que usted dice doctor
todavía no podemos establecer si esta
variante es mucho más resistente a las
vacunas actuales eso también está por
definirse porque se ha dicho eso sí está
claro que fue la causante del último
pico que presentó colombia a mitad de
año y el pico precisamente a colombia le
ayudó a reducirlo el avance rápido de la
vacunación que hubo en el país para esos
meses
si efectivamente no se conoce todavía
qué tan efectiva son las vacunas pero lo
el comportamiento que tuvo el pico y la
vacunación nos hace suponer de que no
hay un gran problema de pérdida efectiva
de la vacuna con estable artemio es muy
importante que tengamos en cuenta que
esto se establece con el tiempo que se
exponga a las personas a personas
vacunadas y se demora un par de meses en
verificar ese eficacia o no pero hasta
ahora la información que tenemos no se
afecta primordialmente a las vacunas
pero deben continuar los planes de
vacunación adelante para este las demás
variantes que van a suceder claro que sí
doctor bueno con esto ya ponemos chulo
al primer punto de nuestra agenda paso
al siguiente tema que tengo para hablar
con usted y es sobre este estudio
científico que determinó cuál es la
molécula que le permite al coronavirus
entrar a las diferentes células del
organismo esto aparentemente es una
buena noticia supongo yo para que los
médicos y los científicos puedan
determinar otros mecanismos para digamos
rodear al virus al coronavirus y evitar
su expansión o evitar que sea tan
agresivo o simplemente hacer que el
cuerpo pueda dar una respuesta más
rápida que se dice sobre esto
digamos que ya desde el inicio de la
pandemia y ya con el conocimiento previo
de los coronarios se conoce muy bien
cuál es el enlace el receptor se llama
el reflector de ángel designados y ahí
es donde se une el virus lo que se habla
críticas de su penetración dentro de las
células pulmonares o de las células de
otros órganos donde se han identificado
ataques de esas células que están
infectadas claro entre más conozcamos el
virus más oportunidad tenemos para
desarrollar medicamentos vacunas o hacer
neutralización del virus y esto es
importante porque estos avances nos
permiten casi que disecar cuál es el
comportamiento del virus y dónde lo
podemos afectar esta es una noticia más
que trae la ciencia para hacer nuevos
desarrollos y seguimos aprendiendo este
es un virus que vamos a demorar mucho en
entender completamente doctor seguimos
progresando seguimos aprendiendo pero
bueno vamos dando resultados positivos
por lo menos que nos ayuda a entender un
poco más a este virus tercer tema doctor
hoy estamos pero cargados con una agenda
muy cargada de temas y la vacuna de la
farmacéutica moderna que una de las más
extendidas en su uso a nivel mundial ha
mostrado una alta efectividad en cuanto
a la protección contra el coronavirus
algunos lotes han mostrado tener unas
partículas o unos restos de acero en su
composición esto en que se traduce en
palabras simples para el televidente
normal
si digamos que la noticia que hay lo que
tenemos información es que fabricada en
españa en una licencia que dio modernas
unas fábricas españolas la vacuna que se
exportó a japón demostró en un lote la
presencia de trazas de acero es esto que
significa pues que obviamente éstas
estos lotes al estar contaminados con la
sustancia que no está dentro de la
vacuna se desecha por qué es importante
la noticia porque explica que todos los
países independientemente de comprar las
vacunas deben verificar todos los
procesos de seguridad que hay que hacer
lo que llamamos una tecnovigilancia una
de farmacovigilancia reactivo vigilancia
a estas vacunas y cuando sucede algo de
esto pues reaccionar oportunamente
lo que se espera es que algunas planas
fueron inoculadas con esta vacuna y que
no vaya a tener algún impacto en su
salud sin embargo puede informaciones
que esas vacunas no van a ser utilizadas
en el futuro y es un llamado pues a la
comunidad científica para estar alerta
de lo que puede suceder con starbucks
queda aclarado el tema doctor y para el
cierre doctor le pregunto por esas
denuncias que han hecho algunas mujeres
que ya recibieron las dos dosis de las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 o una dosis
dependiendo del tipo de vacuna y han
dicho y han denunciado que están
presentando problemas irregularidades en
sus ciclos menstruales que se sabe en la
comunidad médica y científica sobre este
tema que se ha investigado al respecto
algunas de estas de las personas durante
los estudios ha manifestado alteraciones
del ciclo menstrual pero recordemos que
estas alteraciones del ciclo menstrual
pueden tener muchas explicaciones la
misma explicación del encierro de las
situaciones emocionales de la angustia
por vacunarse o por no recibir la vacuna
es decir que hay algo variable también
se ha sabido que si hay estas
alteraciones el periodo menstrual
también son reversibles es decir que son
temporales en el tiempo no se ha
demostrado lo que pueda ser permanente
sin embargo están en desarrollo de los
estudios a mediano y largo plazo si hay
algún impacto en la menstruación es o en
el ciclo menstrual de las mujeres pero
vacunar en una mujer es seguro no altera
ni la fertilidad
estas relaciones con ciclo menstrual son
transitorias no impactan en la salud
femenina y por eso las vacunas en las
mujeres siguen y seguirán siendo seguras
incluso en mujeres embarazadas y
lactantes son también muy seguras y por
eso a pesar de que hay información
acerca de eso como le repito puede
reversible es temporal y no impide la
vacunación así que las mujeres tienen
porque tenemos más evidencia de su
beneficio que de sus pies nos pues
aclarado el tema doctor pérez muchísimas
gracias hoy larga consulta teníamos
muchos temas doctor pero gracias por
haber resuelto todas estas dudas para la
teleaudiencia de france 24 muchas
gracias doctor pérez
cambiamos de tema en medio de récords de
casos hospitalizaciones y también
escasez de vacunas 25 millones de
estudiantes mexicanos regresaron a las
aulas para recibir clases presenciales
esto marcó todo un debate en la sociedad
mexicana por supuesto porque hay padres
que creen que todavía no es el momento
para hacerlo mientras que el presidente
de la nación andrés felipe lópez obrador
ha dicho que ya es momento de regresar a
las clases veamos
mateo ansía reencontrar a sus compañeros
y su mamá tiene más miedo a los efectos
del encierro que al coronavirus creo que
es importante con todas las medidas que
ya tenemos con toda esa comunicación que
vamos a tener llevarlos a la escuela
para que logren tener lo que lo que lo
que los niños necesitan en la escuela lo
que van a socializar
mateo está contento y promete cuidarse
la verdad si necesitaba ir a la escuela
y pues ya lo voy a hacer las autoridades
limpiaron escuelas y establecieron
medidas sanitarias pero dado el auge de
la pandemia el regreso ha generado
polémica
a miembros de la disidencia magisterial
que unos 50.000 maestros rechazan la
medida y advierten que no asistirán
el presidente ha sido enfático en la
necesidad de volver a las aulas ya no es
posible tener a los niños encerrados en
las casas no es posible eso se les está
causando un gran daño la cantidad
pero al ser voluntario el regreso hay
papas que por ningún motivo llevarán a
sus hijos nora de demasiado riesgo la
verdad es que vale mucho la pena yo
prefiero tener a mis hijas aquí que
exponerlas a una enfermedad que no sé
cómo va a resultar
y su hija dice estar de acuerdo es más
seguro más tranquilo porque tampoco
quiere enfermar a mis abuelitos ya que
nosotros nos hemos estado cuidando mucho
y para que vayamos y desperdiciamos todo
ese tiempo que estuvimos aquí no vale la
pena entonces las autoridades
descartaron aplicar pruebas kobe y están
conscientes de que podrá haber contagios
en los colegios pero de darse el caso no
van a cerrar toda la escuela sino que
harán una intervención selectiva así
será la vuelta a clases universal y la
más complicada en la historia del país
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador hago la aclaración vamos
entonces a ciudad de mexico allí hay
recortes de casos vamos a profundizar
entonces en este tema con mario'
carbonell nuestro corresponsable en la
capital mexicana
-mario gracias por estar con nosotros en
el programa y comencemos entonces
haciendo un balance de esos primeros
días de clases y qué dicen las
autoridades que dicen los mexicanos
hola pues la secretaria de educación
publica aún debe un balance oficial del
retorno a clases toda vez que hasta el
momento el único reporte que se tiene
fue dado a conocer por la secretaria del
final gómez el martes pasado en donde
dijo que el lunes habían arrancado
clases presenciales en cerca de 11
millones 400 mil alumnos en alrededor de
120 mil escuelas que abrieron con el
apoyo de cerca de un millón de docentes
no obstante este reporte es preliminar
ya que la mayoría de los planteles se
aplica un esquema mixto entre virtual y
presencial de modo que las cifras reales
se darán a conocer hasta la próxima
semana estados como sinaloa y baja
california sur tuvieron que atrasar este
retorno a las aulas debido a las
afectaciones del huracán nora y en otros
estados los profesores de la disidencia
magisterial decidieron no volver a
clases hasta que se cumplan las demandas
de sus pliegos petitorios que son varias
es el caso de michoacán de oaxaca de
chiapas e incluso de guerrero por otra
parte hubo reportes de algunas escuelas
que tuvieron que cerrar luego de haber
detectado casos sospechosos o positivos
confirmados de kobe 19 son pocas pero
hay reportes de tres escuelas en jalisco
dos en guanajuato una en puebla y una en
morelos y pues esto seguramente seguirá
ocurriendo
varios que es todo un debate lo que está
viviendo la sociedad mexicana pero quien
tal parece que tiene la situación muy
clara es el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador esto fue lo que
dijo escuchemos
aunque continúan los contagios se ha
reducido considerablemente el número de
hospitalizaciones y de fallecimientos
por covite la principal razón de esta
disminución en la intensidad de la
pandemia es el programa nacional de
vacunación
que ha funcionado con eficacia y ha
llegado a todos los pueblos de mexico
bueno para el mandatario mexicano ya hay
que regresar a las clases cambiemos de
tema mario y le pregunto ahora por ese
estudio que están haciendo las
autoridades mexicanas sobre la vacuna
cubana abdalá para ver si compran lotes
de esta vacuna cubana para inocular la
allí en mexico que han dicho lo poco que
sabemos es que tiene más del 90 por
ciento de efectividad pero que dicen las
autoridades mexicanas
así es el comité de moléculas nuevas de
la comisión federal para la protección
contra riesgos sanitarios cofepris dio
su opinión favorable al uso de
emergencia de está vacunada la
desarrollada por científicos de cuba
está este comité es una instancia de
consulta de la cofepris que es el órgano
encargado de autorizar los fármacos en
el país no obstante esta opinión
favorable no implica que de inmediato se
vayan a adquirir dosis de esta vacuna y
se vayan a aplicar tiene que pasar
todavía una serie de pruebas de fases
pero de lograrse pues ya sería la octava
marca de vacuna que se aplique en el
país es recordar que el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador en su
reciente informe de la nación hizo una
mención de agradecimiento al gobierno de
cuba por el apoyo brindado a mexico
durante la pandemia también a otros
países pero bueno es destacable esta
estrechez que hay con los cubanos varió
precisamente le quería preguntar por la
vacunación pues pese a que el presidente
dice que la vacunación está avanzando en
mexico hay escasez de dosis para los
jóvenes que son los que están empezando
el ciclo académico y muchos de los
padres han tenido que buscar beneficios
o amparos dentro del sistema de salud
para poder recibir dosis para inocular a
sus hijos
el gobierno de méxico reitera que no
tiene considerado vacunar a la población
menor de edad asegura que el riesgo que
corre este segmento de la población es
muy bajo y que la ms no lo indica no
obstante algunos padres de familia ya
están recurriendo al poder judicial para
que se obliga a las autoridades a
vacunar a los pequeños el propio
presidente de lópez obrador dio a
conocer que son ya 250 amparos ante la
justicia en 19 entidades de la república
y pues en más de 150 el juez ha dado una
resolución favorable a los padres por lo
que se ha comenzado a obligar a las
autoridades a vacunar a los menores a
pesar de la decisión del gobierno el
presidente dice que esto parece una
acción concertada pero no les queda más
que acatar por otra parte es cierto ha
habido un freno en la aplicación sobre
todo de primeras dosis a la población
joven en la ciudad de méxico las
autoridades capitalinas echan la pelota
al gobierno federal aseguran que es la
federación la que les entregan las
tandas y que en las últimas semanas
reconocen
debido más que dosis para completar
esquemas es decir para aplicar segundas
dosis y bueno esperan que esto que se
está dando en cinco de las 16 alcaldías
de la ciudad se regulariza se normalice
a la brevedad varió muchas gracias por
este completo reporte desde ciudad de
mexico ahora vamos a ver cómo está
avanzando la vacunación en américa
latina' para el cierre de esta semana
les presentamos el porcentaje de
personas que han recibido ya el esquema
completo de vacunación ya sea una dosis
o dos vamos a comenzar con chile en este
país el setenta y 1.28 por ciento de la
población ya tiene todo el esquema
completo de vacunación en canadá el 67
puntos 0 8% ya está completamente
vacunado en la isla de anguila en el
caribe
59.27 por ciento de la población no muy
lejos de allí en el archipiélago de
antigua y barbuda ya han inoculado con
esquema completo al 34 punto 45 por
ciento de la población y cerramos en
brásil allí la cifra alcanza el 30 punto
17 por ciento de la población
hablamos ahora de uruguay y allí las
autoridades permitieron la apertura de
las fronteras de este país para que las
personas que tienen propiedades o
inmuebles en territorio uruguayo puedan
entrar al país para ir a visitar
precisamente estas propiedades esto
beneficia a cerca de 90.000 ciudadanos
argentinos que tienen en su mayoría
terrenos cultivos casas de verano
chacras o campos sobre todo en la costa
uruguaya para pasar allí las vacaciones
vamos a conocer detalles con karina de
almas nuestra corresponsal allí en la
ciudad de punta del este en el
departamento de maldonado y karina que
más detalles se sabe de esta apertura
cuáles son las condiciones que busca el
gobierno uruguayo esto es preparando el
terreno de cara al futuro y pensando en
el verano austral que dicen
así es efectivamente a partir del
primero de septiembre los extranjeros
con propiedades en uruguay pueden
ingresar al país entretanto a partir de
noviembre lo podrá realizar todos los
turistas los propietarios deberán
demostrar por medio de un certificado
realizado por un escribano público en
uruguay o por medio de una declaración
jurada tener esos bienes a su nombre se
estima que unos 90 mil argentinos tienen
propiedades en uruguay algunos de éstos
presentaron al gobierno uruguayo una
queja por no haberles permitido ingresar
anteriormente al país y solicitan que se
les exonere de determinados impuestos a
los inmuebles
con esta iniciativa el gobierno uruguayo
en esta primera etapa estaría aprobando
protocolos e implementando medidas
sanitarias de cara a la próxima
temporada estival
karina eso en cuanto a la parte legal
pero qué hay en cuanto a la parte de
salud qué restricciones van a tener
estas personas cuando lleguen al
territorio uruguayo qué requisitos
necesitan en cuanto a bioseguridad para
poder entrar allí a la república
oriental
los extranjeros con propiedades en
uruguay que deseen ingresar al país
deberán tener la pauta completa de
vacunación sin importar cual tipo de
vacuna recibieron deberán tener un test
pcr negativo realizado 72 horas antes
del ingreso al país si son acompañados
por menores de edad de 12 18 años éstos
podrán hacerlo aunque no tengan vacunas
dado que en varios países no se han
facilitado a este grupo etario pero la
familia en totalidad deberá realizar una
cuarentena de dos semanas esta
cuarentena podrá acotarse si se realizan
un test psr negativo a los 7 días el
turismo de los argentinos en uruguay es
muy importante para la economía del país
en el 2019 el 56 por ciento del turismo
externo fueron argentinos es por eso que
el gobierno está realizando está medidas
aunque actualmente uruguay es caro para
los argentinos debido al cambio de la
moneda
karina y para finalizar hablemos de la
situación sanitaria como cierra este
país esta semana en cuanto a contagios
vacunación hospitalizaciones y
fallecidos
estas medidas se enmarcan en un contexto
sanitario muy favorable para uruguay
donde actualmente el 70% de la población
ya recibió dos dosis de la vacuna se
está ejecutando un plan de refuerzo con
una tercera dosis del laboratorio pzifer
y los fallecimientos y los contagios
están descendiendo esto le permite al
gobierno uruguayo proyectarse de cara a
un turismo externo mientras tanto ya se
han habilitado también fiestas y
conciertos multitudinarios por lo que
los expertos están siguiendo el trazo de
los nuevos casos recientemente 25
personas contagiadas asistieron a
fiestas clandestinas oa reuniones
familiares por lo que las autoridades
exhortan a concurrir solamente a las
fiestas que estén avaladas por el
ministerio de salud pública y que
cumplan con los protocolos sanitarios ya
las reuniones familiares mantener las
medidas de prevención
karina muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la soleada pero todavía fría a
punta del este hay en maldonado y
complemento esta información diciendo
que el sistema nacional de emergencias
informó que en los dos últimos días
uruguay no ha registrado fallecimientos
por causas del cob y 19 una noticia
alentadora para este país pero nos vamos
ahora está centroamérica que vive un
repunte de casos de contagio de kobe 19
todo lo contrario a lo que estamos
viendo en uruguay las autoridades han
declarado el estado de calamidad en
guatemala e impusieron nuevas
restricciones como el toque de queda
nocturno mientras que también preocupa
el caso de belice en donde se están
disparando también el aumento de los
casos pero los más preocupantes son
costa rica en donde los hospitales están
colapsados y nicaragua que ha tenido que
regresar a un confinamiento y que ha
roto todos los récords 600 casos nuevos
registrados solamente en 24 horas así
están las cosas
la región centroamericana revive el
inicio de la pandemia en guatemala el
repunte de kobe 19 motivó a la
declaración de estado de calamidad
allí el primer mandatario alejandro
giammatei impuso la prohibición de todos
los eventos en masa ya sean educativos
deportivos o religiosos en ese país la
situación desborda los hospitales el 97
por ciento de la capacidad está
comprometida más al sur en costa rica se
registra un incremento de
hospitalizaciones y muertes por kobe 19
de un 21 8% en su vecina nicaragua el
independiente observatorio ciudadano de
kobe 19 pidió a la población
urgentemente realizar una cuarentena
voluntaria para contrarrestar las
consecuencias de eventos masivos
convocados por el gobierno que asegura
que la situación de salud está bajo
control el impacto la inequidad de la
vacunación se refleja en las cifras de
contagios y muertes guatemala costa rica
y panamá lideran la lista
la organización panamericana de la salud
alertó de un aumento significativo de
casos en la región y calificó de
inaceptable la disparidad entre quienes
pueden acceder a la vacuna y los que no
necesitamos que los países
vacunen tan pronto reciban las vacunas
si bien los países administran las dosis
rápidamente esto es solo el comienzo a
medida que reciben más dosis y también
envíos más grandes los países deben
asegurar que que los sistemas logísticos
puedan absorber estas dosis y que se
garantice la cadena de frío mientras los
contagios van en aumento y se intenta
seguirle el rastro a la variante delta
en la región guatemala ya registra los
primeros casos de la nueva variante muy
ya lo bueno ustedes es preocupante la
situación en costa rica y en nicaragua
vamos a ver más cifras de costa rica
para dimensionar cómo es la situación
allí para el cierre de esta semana la
cifra aproximada de casos ya supera los
469 mil unas 5.500 personas han
fallecido en costa rica mientras que el
23 puntos 73 por ciento de la población
ya ha recibido el esquema completo de
vacunación en las dos últimas semanas de
los casos que han sido reportados en
costa rica de kobe 19 el 59 punto 49 por
ciento de ellos corresponde a la
variante delta
y vamos a profundizar en la situación
que está viviendo con costa rica con
cindy regidor nuestra corresponsal de
france 24 en la ciudad de san josé es
cindy me comienzo por preguntarle por la
situación puntual de este país del pico
de contagio que la noticia que estamos
cubriendo larga ola de contagios y no da
tregua y en costa rica
hola santiago así es la tasa de contagio
volvió a subir en los últimos días
existe un aumento acelerado en el
contagio de coronavirus el 88% de los
cantones reportaron incrementos de casos
según el más reciente informe de la
comisión nacional de emergencias la
semana pasada fue la tercera con mayor
cantidad de casos de toda la pandemia es
así que la alerta naranja-- continúa
vigente para todo el territorio nacional
lo que significa que se halla en un
nivel de riesgo muy alto descuidos como
rompimiento de burbujas sociales la
falta del uso de la mascarilla provocan
este aumento dijeron las autoridades que
llaman a la población a que cumpla las
medidas sanitarias mientras tanto las
medidas de restricción de movilidad se
flexibilizaron por ejemplo a partir de
septiembre fue eliminada la restricción
vehicular de los fines de semana durante
el horario diurno
cindy veíamos la cifra 59.49 por ciento
de los casos registrados en las dos
últimas semanas corresponden a casos de
la variante delta tal parece que se está
moviendo muy rápido por el territorio
costarricense que dicen las autoridades
sobre esta variante
la variante delta que es más
transmisible ha sido identificada en
todas las provincias y se propaga
rápidamente en todo el país según
reportó el instituto costarricense de
investigación y enseñanza en nutrición y
salud por lo que si es parte de las
razones por las que vemos este
crecimiento en la tasa de contagio
actual en general vemos que en el país
los contagios y las muertes por kobe 19
aumentaron en un 20% según el ministerio
de salud el número de hospitalizaciones
también ha subido y para frenar este
nuevo pico se ha adelantado la segunda
dosis de vacuna en jornadas masivas de
inoculación actualmente hay 1.2 millones
de habitantes que completaron su esquema
de vacunación y en total 3 millones de
personas con al menos una dosis de un
total de 5 millones de habitantes la
vacunación se acelera a medida que
llegan lotes de biológicos comprados y
donados justo en estos días el país
recibió la mayor cantidad de dosis en
una sola semana con casi 700 mil dosis
en total sin dijimos por un momento
costa rica- hablemos ahora de nicaragua
allí también es muy complicada la
situación y sobre todo es muy complicado
recolectar cifras porque no el gobierno
no ha hecho un seguimiento riguroso de
la situación veamos más o menos cómo
están aproximadamente allí las las cosas
se habla de más de 11 mil 700 casos de
contagio unas 200 personas han fallecido
tal vez más es un poco más tal vez y
solamente el 3.0 2% de la población esto
es prácticamente nada tiene el esquema
completo de vacunación sinde entonces
así las cosas con este récord también de
600 casos registrados en las últimas en
24 horas que se sabe de la situación en
nicaragua que dicen allí las autoridades
incluso han llamado una cuarentena
voluntaria
en nicaragua la situación es preocupante
según advierten médicos independientes y
los reportes periodísticos y locales que
registran un aumento de contagios que
sobrepasa por mucho lo que reflejan las
cifras oficiales incluso las cifras que
brindan las autoridades aunque son bajas
en comparación con esos otros reportes
independientes también evidencian un
aumento en la última semana la
organización panamericana de la salud
detalló que de los 153 municipios del
país 144 se han visto afectados porque
el kobe 19
este incremento se refleja también en
los hospitales fuentes médicas filtran
detalles sobre la saturación de los
servicios en varios centros en todo el
país
el independiente observatorio ciudadano
kobe 19 llamó a la población a una
cuarentena voluntaria mientras por otro
lado el gobierno ha llamado a la
población a disfrutar de unas largas
vacaciones durante la semana del
bicentenario de la independencia de
centroamérica
exonerando del impuesto al valor
agregado a establecimientos de venta de
alimentos bebidas y hospedajes para así
promover el turismo
y muchas gracias por este reporte desde
san jose les cuento brevemente otras
noticias destacadas a lo largo de la
semana las autoridades de chilé
anunciaron que pese a que el país es uno
de los que más ha avanzado en vacunación
en la región y que también los casos han
disminuido las fronteras seguirán
cerradas hasta el 30 de septiembre de
este año para ingresar o para salir de
chile se necesita un permiso especial de
las autoridades mientras tanto en
venezuela fueron detectados casos de la
variante delta en 6 estados de venezuela
desde las autoridades sanitarias
pidieron al gobierno federal que
declarara la emergencia sanitaria por el
aumento de los casos y también por la
lenta vacunación y terminamos en
paraguay en donde noticias positivas
este país cumple 11 semanas consecutivas
presentando un descenso constante
constante de casos de kobe 19 recordemos
que en un momento paraguay estaba
rezagado en la vacunación pero ya se
está adelantando
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el kobe 19 que
también fueron destacadas a lo largo de
esta semana en redes comenzamos con esta
publicación de nuestros colegas de radio
francia internacional astrazéneca y la
unión europea anuncian acuerdos sobre
vacuna que ponen fin al litigio judicial
las partes han acordado un nuevo
calendario para la entrega de vacunas
pendientes que era el punto de la
discordia astrazéneca se había
comprometido a distribuir 200 millones
de dosis que aún no ha entregado a
bruselas ahora con este nuevo cronograma
y sin litigio de por medio la
farmacéutica también se libró de pagar
una sanción millonaria por incumplir
veamos este otro titular se multiplica
el cob y 19 estudiantes contagiados en
california y florida registran récords
en sólo dos semanas después de haber
comenzado las clases cerca de 5 mil 300
estudiantes solamente en el condado de
los ángeles han dado positivo para kobe
19 mientras que en florida las cifras
son peores mil 338 personas fallecieron
en solamente 24 horas todo un récord
estatal y finalizamos con kobe 19
medidas que entrarán o estarán vigentes
en guatemala a partir de s del 2021 el
presidente de guatemala alejandro
giammattei anunció nuevas medidas con el
objetivo de contrarrestar el incremento
de casos de kobe 19
es todo por hoy aquí en kobe 19 la
semana en américa nos encontramos la
próxima semana sigan cuidando si
protegiéndose el kobe 1980 para bocas
lávese las manos y sigan viendo france24
siga con nuestra programación
[Música]